it's great to welcome back to the
program Steve Almond who's the author of
the new book bad stories what the hell
just happened to our country super
interesting book Steve and it really
ties together elements of history that
are connected in differing degrees to
what we're sort of observing now
happening in the country politically as
well as a discussion of sort of the more
present-day what's sort of like the big
picture of the concept of bad stories
from a sort of socio-cultural
perspective what does it mean a bad
story right so it's I know you're deeply
impressed by how sophisticated my
terminology is right I'm not a political
scientist and I'm kind of a recovering
journalist I was a journalist sort of
full-time for many years but haven't
done that for a while I'm a short story
writer and essayist and I think of I
think of story as kind of the central
the the central mechanism by which human
beings construct reality they tell
stories about themselves the in you know
the world inside them in the world
around them and if those stories are
good stories if they're stories that are
sort of predicated on kindness and
forgiveness and the desire to be a
better person you know sort of both
within your personal ambitions and also
in a kind of general like Christ as a
figure was saying we should be kind and
merciful to people that if we tell those
good stories we end we end up getting
good results
but the capacity to tell stories which
is what sets us apart from any other
species on the planet and what allowed
us to survive early because stories were
the thing that allowed us to extend the
bonds of human kindness beyond just clan
loyalty we were able to believe in this
beautiful fiction known as the common
good right that we could do things that
would be mutually beneficial to people
we didn't even know or you know that
weren't part of our immediate clan or
our tribe that's a beautiful idea that
storytelling is redemptive but there are
also bad stories which are stories that
are fraudulent that are intended to sow
discord that are intended to sort of
selfishly aggregate power and wealth
within a particular group and those
stories
lead to bad outcomes when you tell a bad
story you always get a bad outcome and
the book is an effort to kind of step
back from history because I think a lot
of people right now are feeling
justifiably confused and distressed and
I think that's partly sort of by design
when you're when you're part of a regime
that's interested in fomenting
propaganda and conspiracy theories and
ginning up people's negative primal
emotions that's a lot of the game as you
know is to keep people distressed and
confused to not give them a chance to
get the bigger picture that makes them
more pliant they become objects of
history you've just passively consumed
things maybe even just passively are
distressed about things rather than
active participants in a democracy who
support candidates and causes and hit
the streets when they feel they're
called to do so so the book is an effort
to deconstruct all the bad stories that
that I think really resulted in the bad
outcome of the 2016 election - to step
back from the hot takes and I have a
grand idea of how it all happened
because it all happened for really
complicated reasons that date back well
before the founding of the country it's
not like you're just going to come up
with one unified theory it's a whole
bunch of things colliding it's
interesting the term bad stories the
stories you identify are very different
than the stories that sort of the modern
American right-wing is identifying as
problematic but they've started to use
the term narrative as an almost
perjorative when trying to criticize
some of the so called bad stories or
narratives that the left is pointing out
as sort of the causes of some of the
problems that we're experiencing so even
though the stories you identify are very
very different from the ones that the
sort of modern right-wing movement has
identified the concept of the bad story
or the misleading narrative it's very
present sort of across the political
spectrum right now and I wonder if
there's something to that something to
the sort of realization of the
background narratives and how they
impact modern-day politics yeah well of
course I mean look one of the arguments
that I'm making in the book is you've
got to stop looking at outcomes and
result
and I think people are starting to
realize that you know sticking your head
in the news cycle these days it's like
sticking your hand and a blender
it's just nothing good is gonna come of
it there's too much coming at you but if
you can step back and say okay these bad
outcomes are the result of some bad
stories so what are those stories that
individual voters are telling themselves
that politicians and demagogues are
telling and you know one of the central
stories that we've been telling
ourselves for as long as we've had a
country is America is a representative
democracy right all men were created
equal but we know that's a bad story we
know the guy who wrote those words owned
slaves owned other human beings we know
that slaves couldn't vote you know the
women couldn't vote for half the history
of this country and we know that that
legacy of a minority party was deeply
unpopular but essentially plutocratic
ames is always gonna try to keep people
from voting we have voter suppression
that's rampant you know we we have a
whole electoral system the electoral
college in which somebody can quote
unquote win the presidency by losing by
3 million votes that was slave-owner
math the whole purpose of the electoral
college was to bring slave-owning States
into the Union and these are things we
don't discuss a lot but until we start
to discuss them America is not going to
be a representative democracy when 3.5
when when a vote in Wyoming counts three
and a half times more than a vote in
California or Texas or New York you
don't have one person one vote you don't
have a representative democracy so some
of this is a fundamental kind of
Reformation in the way that we think
about the stories that we're told to
accept but some of it also has to do
with culturally how we position
ourselves people on the right figured
out a long time ago that in order to do
well as a minority party they were gonna
have to reach people's emotions and get
them to disregard policies that were
almost never in their best interests so
if you could make the debate about
affordable health care a debate in which
one side is telling frightened older
people you're gonna face a death panel
the state is taking over your medical
care and bureaucrat is going to decide
whether you live or die in a very basic
way like a storytelling way they've
ratcheted up the stakes and it's very
convincing when you're told not just
they're coming for your guns
your religion or your way of life but
they're coming for your life that's hard
to fight against when the other side is
stuck saying no that's not true all we
want to do is make health care a little
bit more affordable but for people who
are don't have as much money so there's
a kind of inherent narrative advantage
that the right wing has and they have
really for the over the last 40 years
gone further and further towards
inflaming what richard hofstadter the
the cultural historian calls the
paranoid style in American politics in
fact I think that there's so many
examples of that and I've pointed this
out for a long time we're on many issues
there's a coherence to the story we get
from the write that is not matched by
the left not because of a failing of the
left but because reality is often much
more complex abortion is like a really
really good example right hey listen
abortion is murder murder is bad
abortion should be banned the position
on the left is not the opposite of that
it's a much more nuanced detailed and
complex story or narrative for lack of a
better term and when it comes to modern
media it just fails in opposition well
I'll give you an even better example of
climate change the story that left is
stuck telling is hey we've been roaring
drunk on petroleum for 200 years the
planets thermostat has gone kablooey
and unless we radically change our
convenience based way of life we are
going to doom future generations to a
horrors an apocalyptic landscape that
that's not a story anybody wants to live
in but the story on the right is hey a
bunch of egghead scientists are running
a scam and they want to make you feel
guilty for driving an SUV do the math
here you know whose story is more
psychologically convincing what's
troubling is that and this is why I
write a lot in the book about the
Fairness Doctrine is that our Fourth
Estate there used to be a time where
government essentially said if you're
going to use public licenses to you know
to air your radio program or your TV
show if we're going to have mass media
there needs to be we need to have some
governor you know some mechanism by
which we regulate that so it doesn't
become propaganda and when the Fairness
Doctrine disappeared in 1987 I'm sure
you know this David the right
when radio just rose like an absolute
monolith yep it took over the am dial
and FoxNews had followed shortly after
that and what you had was essentially at
the beginning of for-profit demagoguery
or I shouldn't say the beginning the
acceleration of a kind of demagoguery
that was now combined with the power of
mass media and you you know you you
create a situation where you build the
viewer or the listener with this kind of
paranoid ideation where there's only one
world you know sort of only one way that
it can be and everybody's out to get you
especially the government and Trump
didn't have any new ideas his ideas are
completely recycled they're really
borrowed from talk radio and he didn't
lead a movement he just inherited an
audience share that we created through
our deregulation of the way that media
operates you now have media outlets that
are literally paid to mangle hub
everyday 24/7 they're paid to mangle
hook they're paid to frighten old people
mostly old white people who feel
understandably a sense of declining
utility and a kind of Terror at this
Brown wave demographic shift in the
country and rather than preaching a
politics of economic uplift of saying
hey listen we got it we got some serious
problems and we're only gonna solve them
together the way they keep these people
kind of on the drip is by saying
actually there are a bunch of people out
there they're Brown they're Muslim
they're immigrants they're in that
they're thugs they're in the inner city
and they're out to get you unless you
listen to me and follow my marching
orders they're gonna get you that's
incredibly powerful and they know that
the right has been much more effective
in part as you say because reality is
complex and nuanced and it's also true
that if you're unmoored from a
functioning conscience then you can just
lie and make stuff up Steve in the
limited time we have left one of the
stories you talk about in the book bad
stories is the sort of opportunity or
the chance that Putin and Russia saw
with Trump can you tell us just a little
bit about that yeah I think the story we
tell ourselves is hey the Cold War is
over
1989 came that Berlin wold tear down
that wall right the Berlin Wall came
down we all danced a crappy New Wave
music and it was over America had won
and if your Putin who's sitting over
there in 1989 seeing this and you grew
up believing that his job was to make
Russia great again right you're saying
it's not over and I'm not gonna beat the
United States in a military sense and
I'm not going to beat them in an
economic sense in fact we bankrupted the
Soviet Union trying to do that but I can
see the weakness within their empire
they believe bad stories they have a
whole sort of not state-run but they
have a privatized for-profit demagoguery
kind of propaganda ministry that is
working over there that is convincing
people of things that are patently crazy
and untrue but emotionally very powerful
if I can tap into that and we can find a
candidate who like me believes that
liberal democracy is something to be to
be eliminated or at least eroded I'm in
the money and I think it was an
incredible long shot that Trump was
going to be able to be nominated but
once Putin saw that he was all-in
because Trump is a kind of geopolitical
unicorn you you won't even we've never
had a candidate in America who actually
knows nothing about governance is
completely uninterested in governing and
only wants to win the news cycle and
aggrandize himself and gain more money
he's kind of like the capitalist kids
perfect manager if Manchurian Candidate
and once Putin saw that he realized that
there regardless of whether they
colluded consciously they were
completely on the same page they were
both interested ultimately in degrading
democracy and in particular American
democracy no question about it
the book is fascinating Steve we're
talking about Steve all-men's book bad
stories what the hell just happened to
our country I highly recommend the book
and I really appreciate Steve you coming
on and talking to me about it yeah
absolutely it's a pleasure